[Creepy whistling in the background]
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to "The Joy of Creation: Reborn."
This time, we're going to be focusing on just Foxy.
And if you know, which I'm sure you do, Foxy's a bit meaner than the other animatronics.
Not that the other animatronics are huggy-friendly-happy guys.
Uhh, Foxy, is a bit of a diiick.
I need to preface this, because the developer said that I actually need to take preventative measures about Foxy -
Hi, you look horrifying, Ignited Foxy-
- but I don't know what the preventative measures are.
It has something to do with how Five Nights at Freddy's 2 had you flashing the flashlight
in Foxy's face, and I actually have 90 seconds for this one.
AHH WHAT THE FUCK!!!
WHAT HAPPENED!?!?
Whoa OHH FUCK YOU!!
Ohhhhhh kay
[metal footsteps in the background]
hhhhHHHHIIIIIII
Fuck You, FUCK YOU!!!
I don't know what I did!
Okay?
I'm confused?
I don't like this!
Ohh God!
Okay, alright then.
Umm, umm, um-UMM UMM UMM UMM UMM!!!!!!!!
AHH F---!!!
What the hell is happening!?!?
WHAT THE HELL IS HAPPENING!?!?
I don't know what's goin' on!! D:
[more footsteps]
AHH!!
Ohh Ohh Ohh, what do I do??
What Do I Do!?!?
Ohh what do I do, bro? What do I do flail my arms, bro?
Ohh God.
Ahh I gotta get him when his eyes are white! Not when his eyes are red!
Ooohhh I can't fire until I see the whites of his eyes.
This is horrible.
Ooh God, oh God, Oh God, AHH Fuck You!!
Ohh My God!
Oh My--- FUCK YOU!!
I CAN'T TOUCH HIM!!!
AHH GOD!!
Ahhh.
Eaahhh.
Eahhh.
Oh God, wait, Wait, No! I'm not ready!
FUCK OFF!!
(half crying-laughing)
This is horrible...
Okay, alright, Okay, Alright, BRING IT ON!!!
Oh God! SCREW YOU!!
What is he doin'??
What is he DOIN'?!?!
AHH!! Oh God!
Oh God, Oh God, Oh God. Okay, alright, I'm out, I'm outie, I'm outie.
Whoa God.
Oh God.
(Whispers) He's right behind me.
[footsteps again]
oooOOHHH!!
Ah! FUCK YOU!!
Ohh God, am I trapped??
I'm trapped. Oh God!
I'm Fucked!!
AHHHH! FUCK YOU!!!
FUCK OFF!!!
AH! FUCK OFF!!!
Fuck You! Man! That's such bullshit!
Oh my God!
Aaaahhhh!
Aaaaahhhh!
Aahh! Aahhh!
(panting slightly)
Is that a thing?
Oh, that's not a thing.
Ohhh I don't know where the things are!
OOooohhhHH I don't know where the things are!
OOoooohhhhHH I don't know where the--- FUCK OFF!!!!!!
I'm sweating already.
Oh.
I'm not ready for this.
Ohh this is every--- Nah! FUCK YOU!!
Fuck off, man!
I'm not ready!
I don't know where I'm going, I keep walking into the same corner... Ohh God.
Oh. Fuck me.
That's a thing.
AHH! That was way too fast!
That was WAY too fast!!
Swiggity sue-swoo, fuck you.
(moaning/crying again)
(whispers) oh my God
AHH F--- oh ho ho ho oh my God, that's soo bad.
(half crying again)
AHH!! Ohhh Fuck Me. God ag--- ga fuckin'! Fuck!!
How Do I Get Away From You?!?!
Ahh! ahhhhHHHHHH
I don't know what happens to trigger his eyes going red.
aaaAAAAHHHH!!! FUCK OFF!!!!
(Sniff) I don't wanna play!!
I don't wanna PLAY!
I don't wanna PlaAaAy!
If this was VR...
... Holy shit
Ahh! Fuck off! Fuck off! Fuck you.
Whatchya doing?
What're you doing?
AHH!!!
Oh my God that's so scary!!
(Sniff) It's soo scary!!
(Sniff) It's so scary, man.
What the fuuuck??
What the--- hiii.
(Whispers) He's way too close..
Ohh..
OHH he's creepin'!
Ohh, he's creepy.
He creeps.
Ahh! Fuck off.
Ohhh--- Where am I--- God I'm stuck!
(Markiplier mating call)
(Squeals) AH!
Ohhh dead end dead end dead end dead--- AHHH Fucking HELL!!!!
(Whimpering)
Ahh ohh uhm no no no no
AHH FUCK!!!
(Crying again)
(Whimpering) Oh my God...
Oh my... God...
(Mechanical footsteps)
AHH!!! Okay--- AHH FUCKING---
aaAAaaaHhhhh
This is literally the scariest shit I've ever seen.
This is probably the scariest shit I've ever seen in any game I've ever played.
Holy shit. I'm trying to---
- I'm trying to rack my brain for intelligent commentary to say- oh that is not good, he's got me trapped.
Hi, buddy.
Hey friend.
Hey friend!
How ya doin'!
How ya doin' friend?!
OHH don't kill me don't kill me don't kill- Ohh Fuck You~!
Doodley doodley doodley doodley doodley doo
Oh my God, this is the worst. This is the---
You see, the problem is: I can't look ahead of me...
uhh I can't look ahead--- God how I keep getting--- I keep getting trapped in these rooms.
Hi...
Hi..
oOhHaHaHah Ohh my God...
Oh my God, I don't even know where any of the objects are.
Eauhhh
Here we go.
AHH ah ah
wooh
Wooh
Woohh
WOOOH
*focused Markiplier*
I've gotta--- WAHH! I gotta, like, listen. That's what I gotta do. I gotta, like listen. I gotta, like listen,
behind me, for the sprinting moments...
And then when he sprints, I--- Ahh fuck I failed my objective.
But that doesn't matter!
I got Foxy's number :3
Uh oh.
Uh Oh.
Ohh hey!
Fuck you!!!
Oh I'm trapped! I can't get around him!
Oh God! Ahh FUUU---!
(Sad Markiplier noises)
I still haven't even seen him kill me, 'cause my eyes have been glued shut every time he gets me.
Holy shit.
Ohh he's the scariest...
Come on. Come on. You're wasting my time, buddy!
You're wasting everybody's time - stop looking at the light!
Stop being a fucking creeper! There we go.
Okay. Goodbye~!
Okay.
Here we go.
4?
AH -oh oh that was way too close.
Whoooa
Whoa Nelly give me the last one last one last one LAAAAst one. Come on. Come OONN!
Give it to MEEE!
Give it to meeehh.
Where is it?
I want it. Come on!
Goddamnit.
Eauhh!
Ha! That's it! YES! I DID IT!!
I DID- Fuck you!
FUCK YOU, BITCH.
COME AT ME BRO.
FUUUUUUUUCK YOUUUUUU
I did it. Okay. We're good.
Whoa Nelly, holy shit.
That. Was. Amazing.
Wooow.
That was well done.
Okay, hang on. Hi, Foxy what're you---
Lemme get a good look at you.
Uh oh.
Now that was interesting. Foxy had a unique mechanic that was different than everyone else's.
That was awesome!
That was terrifying!
That was so frickin' scary!
That was like one of the scariest things I've ever seen in a game. It was amazing. So cool.
Such a good way to implement Foxy.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
I don't know if I'ma try to beat Bonnie's, he's kinda similar to Freddy,
but as this game gets developed, we'll see what happens in later episodes.
So, thank you again, and as always - I will see you. In the next video. Buh bye!
[End music]